we have witnessed these large-scale
joint military drills that are going on
between the South Koreans and the
Americans what we've seen is this big
wave of amphibious vehicles come up from
the sea land on the beach and then
groups of Korean artillery and infantry
have come off of those vehicles and they
have run up through this beach in waves
and then into this Forest here we can
just show you the positions that they've
taken up here now what they are
simulating is the scenario of a
contested Beach and it's very clear who
or what power might be the intended
potential enemy in a simulated scenario
like this and of course it is North
Korea because these drills are happening
at a time when tensions on the Korean
Peninsula are as bad as they've been for
many years and these drills are
significant because it is the first time
these drills have been undertaken at a
scale like this for five years and the
fact they are happening again after that
Hiatus of five years where relations
between the two were a little better
than they have been is very significant
this will no doubt elicit a response
from North Korea it already has and it
will contribute to that further
deterioration in relations